>> Tucker: EARLIER THIS WEEK,
NEW YORK POLICE ARRESTED THE
OWNER OF A BAR ON STATEN ISLAND.
APPARENTLY, THE LOCKDOWN RULES,
AND THE SCHOOL SUPPLIES YOU,
ONLY APPLIED IN THE REPUBLICAN
VOTING PARTS OF STATEN ISLAND.
I WAS SO OBVIOUSLY POLITICAL,
THE WHOLE THING, THE PROTESTERS
CAME.
YOU COULD WALK TWO BLOCKS FROM
THE BAR WITHOUT ANY OBJECTIONS
FROM THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT.
TODAY, THE OWNERS OF MAX PUBLIC
HOUSE MET WITH CITY OFFICIALS.
BRINDLEY DIDN’T GO WELL, HERE’S
WHAT THEY TOLD US A SHORT TIME
AGO.
>> THINKS TUCKER, THANKS FOR
BRINGING THESE CAMERAS OUT HERE
TO MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS WE BEEN
CLOSED SINCE THESE RECENT
EVENTS, AND WE’VE TAKEN A
DIPLOMATIC APPROACH.
WE PLEADED WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
CHAIRS DO WORK WITH US AND TO
ASSIST US IN SOME WAY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT HASN’T
HAPPENED.
THE TIMELINE HAS ENDED, AND
WE’RE HERE TO TELL YOU THAT
MAC’S PUBLIC HOUSE IS OFFICIALLY
OPEN AND WE WILL NOT CLOSE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING US AS
ALWAYS, AS HIS ATTORNEY, WE HAVE
ADVISED BOTH KEITH AND DANNY OF
THE LEGAL RAMIFICATIONS OF THEIR
DECISIONS.
AS A PROUD STATEN ISLAND OR AND
A PROUD AMERICAN, I STAND IN
SUPPORT.
>> Tucker: WE SHOULD TELL YOU
THAT EVERY SMALL BUSINESS OWNER,
EVERY SINGLE ONE WHO HAS COME ON
THIS SHOW TO EXPLAIN WHAT’S
HAPPENING UNDER CORONA LAW HAS
BEEN HARASSED BY THE STATE THEY
LIVE IN.
IN SOME CASES, ARRESTED, AND A
NUMBER OF CASES ARRESTED.
WE’RE GOING TO MONITOR WHAT’S
HAPPENING WITH MAC’S PUBLIC
HOUSE THROUGH THE WEEKEND.
THIS CANNOT GO ON, IT’S SO
OBVIOUSLY POLITICAL, IT SO
CLEARLY DIVORCED FROM SCIENCE,